maria in flammen mehr als 12.000
menschen fürchten um ihr leben es sind
apokalyptische bilder die die welt
erschüttern
drei tage nach dem brand
kinder suchen nach einer unterlage für
die nacht menschen rennen einem lkw
hinterher aus dem wasserflaschen
abgeworfen werden bilder aus europa 2020
die stimmung ist verzweifelt die
proteste drohen zu eskalieren viele hier
haben nichts mehr zu verlieren
die polizei rückt vor versprüht
tränengas es trifft auch familien mit
kindern haben wir keine menschenrechte
sie kommen mit tränengas und verletzten
unsere kinder gestern wurde hier
tränengas versprüht und alle auch unsere
kinder wurden vergiftet sind das etwa
menschenrechte seit neun monaten lebt
die familie aus afghanistan hier das
jüngste der drei kinder ist im lager zur
welt gekommen es ist wenige wochen alt
die folgen der brandnacht wirken nach
[Musik]
es konnte jetzt zwei tage lang keine
milch trinken mein kind übergab sich
weil es nicht atmen könnte die
katastrophe von moria sie war absehbar
rückblick als 2015 zehntausende
migranten über das mittelmeer fliehen
ist die eu völlig unvorbereitet auch auf
lesbos bricht bald das chaos aus wenn
hier nicht bald was passiert wird blut
fließen es wird tote geben
die eu reagiert ratspräsident jean
asselborn eröffnet im oktober 2015 einen
sogenannten hotspot auf lesbos
flüchtlinge sollen registriert und dann
entweder auf die eu staaten verteilt
oder abgeschoben werden vor allem soll
es schnell gehen können keine camps
ausrichten wo diese menschen dann
wochenlang oder monatelange sind doch
aus dem geplanten durchgangslager wird
eine dauerlösung
schon im märz 2016 leben in dem für 3000
menschen geplanten lager mehr als 5000
migranten versorgung und hygienische
zustände katastrophal
als papst franziskus im april 2016 nach
moria kommt scheint es als könnte die
verzweiflung nicht größer werden
wir sind gekommen um die aufmerksamkeit
der welt auf diese schwere humanitäre
krise zu lenken und ihre lösung zu
erfüllen
[Musik]
doch die welt schaut immer nur kurz nach
moria schon 2016 brennt es mehrfach
males brandstiftung die ursache sei ein
explodierter gaskocher es ändert sich
wenig europa setzt auf den flüchtling
stil mit erdogan der 2016 in kraft tritt
und tatsächlich sinkt die zahl der
migranten für kurze zeit 2017 bietet
sich so eine große chance hätten wir im
jahr 2017 im april 2017 also nur 4000
ungefähr fünf bis 6000 menschen auf
allen inseln waren
romane aufnahmebedingungen gehabt und
genügend asyl beamte dann hätten wir
diese szene an diese schrecklichen lager
von anfang an vermieden
doch es kommt anders 2017 auf lesbos
zweifelte bürgermeister daran dass es
europa wirklich um eine schnelle
verteilung der migranten geht jetzt mit
dem eu türkei deal haben einige die
absicht aus unserer insel eine
gefängnisinsel zu machen dagegen wehren
wir uns im september 2018 leben knapp
9000 menschen im lager moria dreimal so
viele wie einst gedacht die zustände
verheerend dabei hatte griechenland von
der eu so viel geld für die
unterbringung von migranten erhalten wie
kein anderes land insgesamt 2,6
milliarden euro seit 2005 10
es ist sehr wichtig dass wir uns nicht
nur auf die griechen einschließen denn
sie werden darin unterstützt von manchen
dienen auf die schultern kopf manche
europäische regierungen sagen zu
griechenland zeigt härte an der grenze
die die ankommen ermutigt sie nicht dann
kommen weniger menschen
doch das kalkül geht nicht auf und
gleichzeitig fehlt den menschen in moria
jegliche perspektive 2018 trifft frontal
21 die 15-jährige lama und ihre mutter
beide sind schwer traumatisiert die
tochter suizid gefährdet ich habe mich
seit ich hier bin niemals sicher gefühlt
und habe versucht mir das leben zu
nehmen
aber trotz allem will ich glücklich sein
und leben nur nicht an diesem ort hier
gibt es niemanden der uns beschützt
deshalb denke ich im moment oft darüber
nach zu sterben
traumata von der flucht gewalt im camp
viele kinder und jugendliche in moria
entwickeln schwere psychische
krankheiten
deshalb verlangen wir dass diese
menschen die in so großer not sind
evakuiert werden weg von dieser insel
hier entweder nach griechenland oder in
andere eu staaten
doch auch dieser appell wird nicht
gehört
2009/10 campieren die flüchtlinge längst
außerhalb des lagers moria in den
olivenhainen zwischenzeitlich sind es
16.000 menschen darunter kinder die
jahre nicht mehr in einer schule waren
doch europa bewegt sich nicht und was
angesichts der bilder unvorstellbar
scheint wird trotzdem war 2020 kommen
noch mehr migranten nach moria 20.000
sind es im februar
mittlerweile teilen sich 160 menschen
eine toilette 200 menschen eine dusche
und dann kommen corona und der lockdown
die waren eingesperrt über 150 tage
insgesamt am ende ein gesperrt während
wie gesagt draußen das leben weitergeht
dass das einem wahnsinnigen frust und
einer verzweiflung bei diesem
menschenbild ist auch wirklich nahe
liegend nach den ersten corona
infektionen brennt das lager nieder
vermutlich brandstiftung
damit liegt auch die migrationspolitik
der eu in schutt und asche
und während die menschen in moria nacht
für nacht eine sichere unterkunft suchen
bringt die bundesregierung eine woche
mit der frage ob deutschland überhaupt
menschen aus moriya aufnimmt heute eine
erste einigung 1553 menschen 408
familien sollen kommen dürfen
und die griechen bauen ein neues lager
mit deutscher unterstützung
schon jetzt ist klar es wird wieder
nicht platz haben für alle